very
you so this is not only is it the first
time that I've given this talk it's the
first time I've tried to give a talk at
all like this because um often the point
of a talk is new theorems but but all of
you are going to know some of the
theorems I'll talk about today and some
of you may know all of the theorems but
I want to tell you about about new
proofs and of course we're celebrating
this this new book uh just came and I'm
hoping that by the end of the conference
I'll understand the photograph at the
beginning of the book and why it's uh
why it's
appropriate um so uh so what I what I
said in my forward to the book was was
two papers strike me as really important
in in this General literature two early
papers by Gallen chapley the famous
paper on the marriage problem and by
Chaple and scarf the paper that
introduced top trading Cycles but
another important thing about both those
papers is some of the proofs were very
easy and later we
proved other results with harder proofs
but over time the proofs have gotten
easier too so so I want to take you
through some of modern matching Theory
not the way I would if I were just
telling you what are what are the
important Theory theorems and matching
Theory because many of them I still
can't prove in very simple ways but but
I'm going to try to give entirely verbal
proofs in the style of Gail and chapley
so so Gail and chapley have a famous
paragraph at the end of their paper
which notices that that their proofs
about the Deferred acceptance algorithm
are are verbal essentially they say the
argument uh isn't in mathematical
symbols but in English uh no obscure
technical terms one hardly needs to know
how to count yet any mathematician will
immediately recognize the arguments as
mathematical uh while people without
mathematical training might have
difficulty following them so so I think
the name of the game is to have verbal
proofs that are real proofs right that
that don't just say this is a proof
sketch so I feel a little bit in in
giving this talk a little bit as if I
were going to do standup comedy that is
standup comedian has has some idea of
jokes that are presumably funny but but
uh but he knows that unless he delivers
them properly they won't make the
audience laugh so I've got some proofs
that are presumably simple and verbal uh
but unless I deliver them properly and I
haven't tried delivering them before
they they may not seem that way to you
so as in standup comedy I invite you to
Heckle me and the manner of
heckling uh that I suggest is if you
think the proof isn't complete that it's
not a real proof uh tell me what your
objection is and I'll see if I can fix
it in a verbal way and one of the things
you'll see is
um is is
when I start a lot of the things you
know I I prepared this talk by cutting
and pasting some things from from more
traditional presentations so I'm gonna
actually have some some symbols and i' I
left them in here you know some
subscripts when I'm defining the problem
but I'm going to try not to say them and
uh eventually maybe we can make them
disappear entirely so gay and chapley
proposed a onetoone model they called
the marriage model and a many toone
model they called the college admissions
model and it consists of men and women
who have preferences over agents on the
other side agents of the opposite sex
the men and women are disjoint sets uh
and I'll read I'll when I speak with the
preference I'll say man I prefers woman
3 to W to woman two and um and and all
this I assume is very familiar um and
I'll sometimes organize uh preferences
by lists and I'll end the list with if
here's man eyes preference I'll end the
list with man himself and what that
means is people he likes less than
himself he'd rather remain single and uh
I'll I'll say that that would be an
unacceptable match and and especially
today to keep things simple I'm going to
assume that all preferences are strict
so an outcome of the game is a is a
matching it's a function that matches
men and women to one another now in
parenthesis I've got some symbols here
eventually those can go away but that's
what I mean for for today uh so I mean
so it's a uh matching that matches men
and women to one another such that woman
W is matched to man M if and only if man
m is matched to woman W and for all men
and women each is matched to either a
member of the opposite sex or is single
matched to him or herself and everyone's
preferences over matching is determined
entirely by who they are matched to so
the only thing I care about about the
matching is who I'm matched
to and a a matching I'll say is blocked
by an individual if I've matched that
individual to someone unacceptable so
they would prefer to remain single and
blocked by a pair of Agents man a man
and a woman if they each prefer each
other to who they're matched to that's a
matching in question and a matching is
stable if it isn't blocked by any
individual or any pair of
agents
and note that in this simple problem the
set of stable matchings equals the core
of the game right so so the core of the
game is the set of matchings that aren't
blocked by any Coalition of any size and
I've just told you about very small
coalitions but that's okay because if
there was some giant Coalition that
could make all its members better off it
would do do so by marrying them to each
other and the ones who are married to
people they prefer would be a a pairwise
blocking pair so blocking pairs are
sufficient and Gail and chapley proposed
to show that uh the set of stable
matchings is non empty and they did it
constructively by proposing the famous
deferred acceptance algorithm an
algorithm that that plays roles in in
lots of practical Market design problems
the way they they talked about this is
um as an algorithm you should understand
this that what's actually G to go on in
the background is men and women are
going to submit um rank order list of
preferences and then we're going to
operate on them in the computer but they
they talk about in a decentralized way
so we can also think about decentralized
markets of this sort and and it begins
with each man proposing to his first
choice if he has any acceptable choices
and each woman rejects any unacceptable
proposals and if she gets more than one
acceptable proposal she holds the most
preferred and rejects all others and the
fact that she holds but doesn't yet
accept is what gives this algorithm its
name the Deferred acceptance algorithm
we're going to defer acceptances until
there are no more proposals and any man
rejected at the previous step makes a
new proposal to his most preferred
acceptable mate who hasn't yet rejected
him and if no acceptable choices remain
he makes no proposal so no man ever
proposes to an unacceptable mate and no
woman ever holds an unacceptable
proposal and each woman holds her most
preferred acceptable proposal to date
and rejects the rest when I say most
remember she has a transitive list of
preferences and the algorithm stops when
no further proposals are made and at
that that point the Every Woman accepts
The Proposal that she's holding if
and that's the match that we created so
that's the Deferred acceptance
algorithm and what Gail and
chapley proved was that the Deferred
acceptance algorithm for any inputs of
preferences produces a stable matching
and therefore a stable matching always
exists okay now before I make the proof
let me just point out that that's pretty
remarkable because as they noted in
their paper you could have the same
definition of stability but instead of
having men and women matching to each
other from two disjoint sets if you had
what they call the roommate problem U
but the same definition of stability you
can have examples where no stable
matching exists so so this is a
remarkable theorem and the the the
theorem is says that that algorithm I
just showed you the man proposing
deferred acceptance algorithm always
produces a stable outcome and the proof
is first of all the algorithm always
stops because no man proposes twice to
the same woman so there's a point at
which there are no more proposals and
the matching is stable because first no
man ever proposes to an unacceptable
woman and no woman ever holds the offer
of an unacceptable man so the final
outcome isn't blocked by any individual
and neither here's the key neither is it
blocked by any pair a mayor man or a
woman because if man m is matched to his
third choice for instance the way he got
there was he first proposed to his first
choice and was rejected and then he
proposed to his second choice and was
rejected each case he was rejected by an
acceptable man who who that woman his
first choice or his second choice
preferred to him she may not be married
at the final matching to those people
but preferences are transitive so so so
she's married to someone she likes at
least as well as those people and better
than him that's why she rejected him so
there are no blocking pairs so the
matching is stable okay so this is a
completely verbal proof contained in G
and Chap's original
now additionally they proved that yes
please correct there is a step Miss I
mean there is you you've got to get that
transitivity the women's matches are
going up yes so I I did mention
transitivity okay yes absolutely so the
point of transitivity is that the women
do better and better and the woman who
rejected me when I proposed to her has
was was better at the moment she
rejected me and has continued to be at
least as good thank you so that's the
the point of transitivity there okay any
other
Luna okay so furthermore said Gan
chapley that that outcome is op an
optimal stable matching for the men in a
very strong sense it gives each man
their most preferred match that they
could get at any stable outcome so let's
think why that's a remarkable theorem
because often when we think about
markets of marriage markets or firm and
workers what what we and at the moment I
just have each firm wants to employ only
one worker uh what we think is the firms
are competing for the good workers
they're not all on the same side they
can't all be satisfied if you said to
each firm point to the worker you like
best we might all point to a Tilla right
and so we can't all be satisfied but now
the question that we're gonna ask
is don't just point to any worker point
to a worker you could possibly hire and
what we mean by that is point to a
worker who to whom you who you could
hire at a stable matching and the
remarkable thing that this theorem says
is now all the firms point to different
workers no two firms point to the same
worker and so there's a matching where
everyone gets who he's pointing to and
it's a stable matching okay and the way
Jen Chaple showed this is by showing
that no man in the man proposing
deferred acceptance outcome is ever uh
rejected by what I'll call an achievable
woman for for that man and a woman is
achievable for a man if there's some
stable matching at which uh M and W are
matched and uh we're going to show that
no man is ever rejected by an achievable
woman and that means of course when the
algorithm stops we've already seen that
it produces a stable matching when the
algorithm stops every man is going to be
matched to an achievable woman that's
what it means for it to be a stable
match and every man has just gone down
his preference list and is matched to
the most preferred woman who hasn't yet
rejected him which will be his most
preferred achievable woman if no man has
ever been rejected by an achievable
woman okay so I'll show you that there
can't be a first step of the algorithm
at which an achievable woman rejects a
man so supposing up to step K of the
algorithm no man has been rejected by an
achievable woman and at step k w reject
man M who is acceptable to her otherwise
she's certainly not achievable and
therefore because he's reject she's
rejecting someone who's acceptable she
has to be holding on to someone who she
likes better man M Prime so hold that
thought woman W likes M Prime better
than M and I'm going to show you that
that W is not achievable for M and to
show that I have to look at some
matching where the two of them are
matched together and show that it's not
stable but for it to have any chance of
being stable M Prime has to be matched
to some achievable woman for him W Prime
because at a stable matching everyone is
matched to an achievable woman every man
is matched to an achievable woman but we
know that M Prime prefers uh did I call
everybody W here I I meant W Prime uh M
Prime is matched to some W Prime sorry
we know that that M Prime prefers W to W
Prime because W Prime is achievable for
him and no man had yet been rejected by
an achievable War so he hadn't hadn't
yet proposed to W Prime and recall W
prefers M Prime to M so they would be a
blocking pair so there's no such
matching that's stable at which M and W
are matched so there's no firststep k at
which a man is rejected by an achievable
woman and therefore no man is ever
rejected by an achievable woman and
therefore there's an M optimal stable
match
okay so that's in gallon shling now let
me I'm going to show you two more proofs
that the set of stable matchings is not
empty just because they're Illuminating
in their in their own way one of the one
way you could hope to get to a stable
matching is by starting from an unstable
matching finding a blocking pair and
creating a new matching that satisfies
that blocking Pair by matching them to
each other so now you've repaired a
blocking pair okay and everyone else
you're leaving the same except possibly
those people were matched at the
matching you're starting from that has a
blocking pair and they're now single
okay so that's what I mean when I say
that a new matching can be created from
an old one by satisfying a blocking pair
and K in his 1976 book marage stra set
of lectures in French uh he found an
example with a cycle that is the the
thing about trying to find a stable
match this way is it's not monotonic the
blocking pair that we're satisfying gets
better off but their spouses who are now
single are worse off so so as you go
from blocking pair to blocking pair some
people get better off some people get
worse off and kth in his book showed an
example where where that can bring you
back to where you were before right
eventually the people who who were
disadvantaged are parts of blocking
Pairs and uh and they come together and
so he had an open question in his
example there was a path from every
stable matching from every unstable
matching to a stable matching but he had
found an example where there was also a
cycle and he asked whether there might
be some examples where there were only
cycles and you could not uh do this
natural decentralized kind of algorithm
of trying to solve a blocking pair one
at a time and that turns out you have to
be a little careful how you formulate uh
what it means to satisfy a a blocking
pair but if you if you formulate it the
way I just formulated it now then um
then there's always always a path to a
stable matching so what John Vander and
I proved was that uh for an arbitrary
marriage problem there always exists a
finite sequence of matchings that goes
from a an unstable matching to uh a
stable matching where
consecutive uh consecutively you you uh
satisfy blocking pairs yeah Peter had
the
comment historical so in in the original
book all the preferences were complete
so nobody was unacceptable actually uh
and also he married off the spouses to
each other and if you formulated that
way then you can find an example with no
pair path thank you that's why your uh
result was even more surprising because
uh for the original question the answer
was no
actually so so speaking about someone
who thinks about matching and
decentralized matching this seemed to be
a more natural formulation that is when
we see divorces in the the world it's
not always the case that the abandoned
spouses marry each
other um so so that's the formulation
that I'm speaking of but you are quite
right uh that that if I didn't say I
should have said that that there you
know it's a little bit delicate how you
formulate what satisfying blocking pair
is thank you for that that good comment
okay so so the the key the key obstacle
we have to overcome it
whoops I just don't have a statement I
thought here the the key obstacle we
have to overcome is that it's
non-monotonic this process of well maybe
I had that on the previous uh satisfying
blocking pairs isn't monotonic in
participant welfare right the divorced
pairs are being harmed as we satisfy a
blocking pair okay
so let me give you a proof that we can
always find such a pair and let's
consider a matching that has a blocking
pair uh
MW and I'm going to satisfy that
blocking pair and get a new matching
that satisfies it at which I'm and W are
are matched to each other and I'm going
to put M and W in this box this box I'm
going to call box a and a is going to be
a I'm GNA Let It Grow and the in the
absence of monotonic welfare the
monotonicity I'm G to get is I'm
eventually going to put everybody in
this box and then I'll be done and the
property of this box is that there are
no blocking pairs for the latest match
in the box and the match and and
furthermore in the Box there's no one uh
who's who's matched by the latest
matching uh to someone who's outside of
the box okay so I started off very
simply with just a pair that that that
is is matched to each other okay so
there are no blocking pairs for for the
latest matching in in the in the box and
it doesn't match any agent the the
latest matching doesn't match any agent
in the Box agent outside of the box and
now I'm going to keep this process going
and eventually I'll have a lot of people
in the Box who for and there there'll be
no blocking pairs in the box and and no
one
uh no one in the box is matched to
anyone outside of the box by the
matching I'm currently working on and
the matching I'm currently working on
has a blocking pair and it could be that
uh if if neither M prime or W Prime is
in the Box I just add them both to the
box and satisfy them but it but it could
be of course that one of M Prime and W
Prime is in the Box and the other one
isn't so now I'm going to add the one
who isn't say w Prime to the box and
match her to her most preferred Man in
the Box so so she's not going to be part
of a blocking pair anymore because she
had some collection of potential
blocking Pairs and and she's matched to
the best one in the box but the mate of
who she's matched to now may be part of
a blocking pair in the box so I'm going
to let the Deferred acceptance algorithm
operate within the box and the mate will
propose until her offer is held okay and
that every time a proposal is held a
blocking pair has been satisfied and
I've got a new one but that there may be
another mate that that has been divorced
so I just keep operating the Deferred
acceptance algorithm which we know will
will lead to a matching that has no
blocking pairs in the Box I'm just
working on the people in the Box okay
and I'll I'll call that the next one
although there have been some
intermediate uh satisfied blocking Pairs
and
I now have increased the number of
people in a but there but there's now no
blocking pair for the current match in a
neither is anyone in a matched by the
current match to anyone outside of a so
a is growing monotonically and I
continue until everyone is in a and
that's a stable match okay so that's a
way to find a stable matching it's a
more complicated way in a certain sense
than the Deferred acceptance algorithm
but it's per in some circumstances it
might seem like a more natural algorithm
that is you have blocking Pairs and
you're letting them find each other okay
doing that in a practical way in a
decentralized market it converges slowly
it might be hard to find the blocking
pairs there are not so many
decentralized matching markets that that
converge to
stability okay so just incidentally uh
there'll be a quiz on this algorithm
which R verbal description in a
uh this is the algorithm that we now use
to match new medical residents to their
Residency program and Loosely speaking
what's going on here is just deferred
acceptance algorithm but it's with
couples and when you have couples so so
it's a different problem than I just
proved the theorem for but when you have
couples some you can't just do one pass
because couples have to be you have to
elicit from them their preferences for
pairs of matches so my wife and I our
first choice might be two matches in the
Bay Area two job jobs in the Bay Area
our next choice might be two jobs in
Boston and so forth and supposing uh my
wife and I appli to our first choice
pair of jobs and they like us so they
hold our applications and reject some
others but now one of you who might have
been rejected in the first step you
applied to the job that's holding my
application and and that employer likes
you better than me so they hold your
application and reject mine well because
my wife and I our next choice is in two
jobs in Boston the algorithm has to
withdraw my wife from the position
that's holding her offer and that causes
a potential blocking pair to exist
because they had to reject some people
in order to hold my wife's offer but my
wife isn't going to work there so
whenever that happens we add a potential
blocking pair to this side of the
algorithm and then we try satisfying
them one pair at a time to get uh the
final match so so that's why that's an
important kind of process one reason why
that's a kind of important process in
market Des design okay so now just to
get us you know fully warmed up I want
to give you one more proof that the set
of stable matchings is always non empty
and this one is uh especially simple
proof and it uses a definition that I'll
say the matching a matching is
simple if in case it's not stable so
that a blocking pair exists W is is
single unmatched so the only so I'm
allowing blocking pairs for a simple
match as opposed to a stable match
but the only blocking pairs involve
women who are unmarried and it's clear
that the set of simple matchings is non
empty because the matching at which
everyone is unmatched is
simple okay but now let's
consider but I'm going to use just the
observation that the set of simple
matchings is non empty to show you that
the set of stable matchings is non empty
okay the way I'm going to do that is I'm
going to look at the set of stable
matchings is finite set of all matchings
is finite so there are there's some
collection some subset of simple
matchings that are Paro optimal for the
men that is I can't find another
matching that makes every man at least
as well off and some strictly better off
without harming another man and I claim
that when I find that par optimal
matching it's stable and supposing it
isn't stable oh it's simple of course
because it's in the set of simple
matchings it's simple if it's not stable
then there's a blocking pair that
involves an unmatched woman well I can
match her to I can satisfy the the the
blocking pair with her most preferred
man with whom she forms a blocking pair
and that'll make one man better off and
it won't hurt any of the other men so it
wasn't really par optimal so the Paro
the Paro optimal for the men simple
match is the man optimal stable
match therefore not empty okay and
that's a a strikingly simple proof that
turns out to generalize to to more
complicated models of
matching okay so let me tell you some
other theorems other than the fact that
the staple matchings always exist okay
one is constant employment okay it turns
out the set of people who are single is
the same for all stable matchings um
that's an interesting theorem in the
marriage problem it's even more
interesting in the many toone matching
problem when I started to redesign the
medical match one of the things they
said to me is why not look for a maximal
cardinality match match as many people
as possible and what you'll see is this
is going to say to them we're already
doing that when we if you have to find a
stable match then it doesn't matter
which stable match you find okay so uh
so let's prove this by we already know
that there's a man optimal and a woman
optimal stable match and let's take a
look at the man optimal match and the
men who are matched at the man optimal
match and the women who are mat matched
at the man optimal match and similarly
for the woman optimal match well what
can we say about the men who are matched
at the man optimal match compared to any
other staple match well this must be the
biggest set because we have strict
preferences so everyone who's matched to
an acceptable mate prefers to be matched
than to be unmatched and so a man
optimal stable match matches as many
people as possible okay so this set cont
the the set of men matched at the man
optimal stable match contains the the
set of men matched at the woman optimal
stable match and vice versa the set of
women matched at the woman optimal
stable match contains the set of women
matched at the man optimal stable match
but the size of these sets has to be the
same because every man is matched to one
woman so you have so all those
containments have to be non-straight so
they're all the same so the people who
are matched is the same at every stable
match and therefore the people who are
single who are unmatched is the same at
every stable
match okay so now let me General Iz just
a little bit as G and chapley did uh to
many to one matching and now they called
it the college admissions problem and
we're going to have uh a set of colleges
and students just like in the marriage
model except that each college has a
quota College ey has a quota Qi of
students so College ey could have room
for a thousand freshmen uh while each
student is interested in being matched
to only one college and students have
preference over colleges and colleges
have preferences over individual
students and matchings assign each
student to no more than one college and
each College to no more than their quota
of students so there's a little bit of a
Lacuna in this
uh formulation because I haven't told
you what colleges preferences over
entering classes are but Gall chapley
didn't address that and as long as we're
interested in pairwise stability and
instability we don't have to address it
right now I mean it turns out to be
important for other things but that
being the case essentially the same
deferred acceptance algorithm Works to
find a stable match a pairwise stable
match um College C instead of proposing
to its first choice student proposes to
its quota of First Choice students it
propos you it admits a whole class um
the students get
multiple proposals multiple admissions
they they um reject all but the one they
like best which they C and the process
continues and you get a a stable match
and in fact um to each College
admissions problem there's a very
closely related marriage problem in
which we transform each college that has
Q positions into Q colleges that have
one position but have the same
preferences of the college and appear
consecutively in the preferences of the
students in in their preferences for
colleges so so some of the theorems that
I already well one of the theorems I
already showed you the one I just showed
you that the set of people who is single
is the same at every stable match will
through this transformation immediately
carry over to the college admissions
problems colleges that don't fill all
their positions will fill the same
number of positions at every stable
match but we've got more structure we
can say more one of the things we can
say is what's now called the rural
Hospital theorem that says not only um
does each college does each Hospital
fill the same number of positions if it
doesn't fill all its positions it fills
them with the same individuals
okay and this was important when when I
was asked to redesign the match because
in the United States we we're big
importers of of medical graduates we
graduate about 19 today we graduate
about 19,000 graduates of who get MDS
from American medical colleges and
another five or 6,000 who get uh uh dos
doctor of osteopathy who are who who can
become licensed Physicians uh so that
gives us you know around 25,000 medical
graduates but we're trying to fill
35,000 residency positions so lots of
graduates of foreign medical schools
come and they are
disproportionately uh find their
positions at rural hospitals and Rural
hospitals are the American hospitals in
which the customary patients are least
used to dealing with people with Foreign
Accents and and things like that so one
of the things I was asked was okay you
know you can't these rural hospitals
aren't filling all their positions
they're not the most desirable Hospital
do a residency at and I was asked well
okay you can't we've already seen you
can't cause them to to fill more
positions but maybe maybe you could fill
them with different people who who would
um you know speak more vernacular
English and and seem more comforting and
the answer is you can't uh they get
precisely the same people so here's
here's a proof let's look at the doctor
o the the the doctor optimal stable
match for some hospital for Hospital H
that doesn't fill all its positions so
they had a bunch of position positions
but the the last ones are just empty
they're they're just match to themselves
in the last positions okay but Mr di is
matched to them okay and here's a
different potentially stable match I'm
going to show you it's not stable at
which Di has been replaced with DJ that
is everyone is the same except not these
two people and I'm going to show you
that can't happen and why can't that
happen well di is matched to somebody at
know that the the doctors who are
matched are are the same doctors are
matched at some stable matching so so
he's matched to someone who he likes
less than Hospital H this is the uh the
doctor optimal stable match right so
this is the the match the doctors like
best uh he's matched to someone he likes
less which
means the hospital would rather be
matched to him than to leave a position
vacant so he would form a blocking pair
at this match so so he can't be not
matched at a different stable
match can't be not matched to the same
Hospital right so at the time that that
I proved this theorem uh my wife and I
were living in former City Illinois
which was halfway between where the
University of Illinois was and and
Illinois State University where where
she taught and the nearest hospital so
Farmer City Illinois had a population of
2,000 and the nearest hospital was in
the the biggest local Metropolis that
was twice as big and um most of the
residents at that hospital had been
educated in Thailand and our our
neighbors who were all Farmers uh
sometimes thought it was a hard hospital
to go
to
but you can't change if if you need a
stable match and for reasons I'm not
talking about but in the medical
environment you do you can't do better
now can also talk about matches with
with contract and I saw Paul Walk in I
don't see where he is right now PA ah
there you go okay so the same proof I
showed you the same simple proof um that
I showed you for non-emptiness of the
core is going to work in in matches with
contracts if the preferences are are
substitute preferences so uh so here's a
a generalization of the college
admissions problem for I'm keeping it
simple for for one to end matches firms
are going to hire multiple workers
workers are just looking for one um one
job uh and they come with contracts and
the contracts could could be over many
things and uh each firm has strict
preferences or or or orderings over
individual contract pairs who they're
who they're matching to and a matching
is a set of triples uh that matches uh
firm I worker J at Contract
X okay and uh firms have strict
preferences there's a choice function
that that arises from those preferences
and I'm going to say firms preferences
are substitutable if for any set of
pairs j and x and for any two distinct
pairs uh JX and and JP Prime X Prime if
you choose JX when uh JP prime x- prime
is available you also choose it when
they're not available so so firms and
contracts don't have complements maybe
the easiest way to see complements is by
looking at the contrapositive the
refusal functions if um if JX is not
isn't included When J Prime X Prime
isn't available then you don't suddenly
start choosing them when JX becomes
available okay but now we have the
the the definition of stability
uh you know matching is stable if no
worker wants to unilaterally drop his
assigned match no firm wants to drop any
subset of its assigned matches that's
the blocking by an individual part and
there's no blocking pair with a contract
term that uh the worker and the firm
prefer and the theorem you know most
most famously by Hatfield and Milgram is
that a stable matching exists and here's
the proof adapted from milda's proof
that I that I showed you at the
beginning that says the set of stable
matchings is not empty let's look at the
simple matchings that are uh if there's
any blocking pair they involve a worker
who's unmatched then the same trick the
set of simple matchings is not empty I'm
going to look for the firm par optimal
matches um if I find one that that isn't
stable it must it's simple it must
involve a a worker who's unmatched and I
can satisfy that matching to get a new
matching and by substitutability the
firm doesn't want to add any new workers
because now they have this new worker
available but that doesn't make them
want to hire a compliment worker there
are no compliments so so the new
matching is still simple and it's Paro
Superior for the men
so so so the the unstable matching
couldn't have been in the paredo set for
simple matchings okay so it's exactly
the same proof that I showed you for the
marriage problem and it shows that the
set of stable matchings is not empty
um let me skip talking about strategic
Behavior because I I want to finish on
time and I want to tell you a little bit
about top trading Cycles okay and so top
trading Cycles is is in this
great but but complicatedly written
paper by Chaple and scarf in 1974 so so
in volume one number one of the Journal
of mathematical economics and we're
about to celebrate the 50th Anniversary
uh of the paper and of the journal um
and they they describe what they call a
housing market each agent possesses a
single unit of an indivisible good
agents have preferences over all the
houses uh but money can't be used trades
have to be swaps so an outcome is a
permutation of the of the initial
endowments among the agents and they
proved basically a fixed Point theorem
based on a theorem of scarf that said V
is a balanced game and hence the the
market has a non-empty core okay so they
they had a pretty complicated proof that
the core was non-empty and then
literally as an afterthought they wrote
after the proof in section four had been
discovered David gaale pointed out to
the authors a simp constructive method
for finding competitive prices and hence
the points of the core and the algorithm
is top trading cycles and so here's
their verbal proof essentially they they
did it full of notation but but a verbal
proof you have this preference restrict
let's to keep it simple it's not
necessary for this part of the proof um
every agent and house are a node in a
graph they an agent and his initial
endowment and you say to each agent
point to your most preferred house
and every agent points and now you have
uh a graph of degree one so it's simple
to find cycles and uh a cycle must exist
because um every there are as many
agents as houses So eventually a house
has to be pointed to either by someone
pointing to his own house or pointing to
a house that someone else has pointed to
so there are cycles and call that pick
one of those and call it the top trading
cycle and everyone gets the house he's
pointed to they leave the market and now
you do it again with the remaining
houses and U the theorem is that the
allocation you get when everyone has
left the market which must happen in at
most n steps they are n Traders uh is in
the core and the the verbal proof is
think about a a coalition that could do
better could get an allocation it
prefers by trading its
own uh its own Goods uh its own initial
endowments well nobody in that first Cy
ccle can be in this Coalition because
they all got their first
choice therefore nobody in the second
cycle can be in the Coalition because to
make them better off you would have
needed to have one of the houses in the
initial endowment of the first cycle and
so forth therefore there's no Coalition
that by trading its own Goods can get an
outcome it prefers therefore it's in the
core therefore the core is not empty for
any preferences okay so that's top
trading cycles and they here here's
actually their proof I didn't get a
chance to erase that yet um let me give
you two more
theorems one is by Roth and postal and
it was also proved in an obscure way
because because Chaple and scarf weren't
focused on top trading Cycles they were
focused on weak and strong cores and
that gave you a different path to
approach things but when preferences are
strict it doesn't matter what order you
choose the cycles and the way to see
that is just take a look at that first
graph of and all the Cycles in it and
everyone who's in a cycle when when
everyone is poting to their first choice
label them number one and now without
removing any Cycles just ask everyone
who who isn't labeled number one to
point to their best
unlabeled uh outcome and all the Cycles
in that label number two and in this way
you label every uh every node with what
house the person who's pointing to it is
going to get no matter what order the
Cycles are removed in and that's you've
uniquely labeled
all the houses therefore there's a
unique outcome in the core that doesn't
depend on
um on on the order in which you remove
things so there's a family of algorithms
that involve removing things in
different order so now I want to prove
to you that it's a dominant strategy for
every agent to State his true
preferences and I'm going to prove it
not the way I originally proved it but
uh let's say but using a formulation
that you know I got dski and Ori Heitz
and Clayton Thomas have recently
proposed and they say the following
since they say we're g to make it
apparent to you that that you can't do
better than to State your true
preferences and we're going to do that
by giving a an equivalent definition if
you like of what it means to be dominant
strategy we're going to show you that
the procedure that other people's
preferences determine a menu for you and
that we're only going to look at your
preferences when it comes time to from
your menu so from your point of view it
will be like serial dictatorship we're
going to show you a set of things you
could have and we're just going to
consult your preferences to ask you
which one you want and you should tell
us therefore which one you want and the
way they're doing this is remember
uh um the order doesn't matter the order
of Cycles removals so so what they're
going to do is they they're going to
present to you they're going to present
to each person slightly different
version of top training Cycles to you
they're going to say we're going to ask
everyone their preferences but we won't
ask you your preferences until there are
no Cycles remaining that don't include
you and only now will we ask you your
preferences and so when when we ask you
well when there are no cycles that don't
include you here we are there there were
there were some other people who hadn't
given their preferences yet but now
they've given them and now there are no
cycles that don't include you and so
when we look at your preferences you're
going to point to someone and get
whatever you point to and
therefore it should be apparent they say
that it's a dominant strategy to point
to what you want most and therefore to
State your true preferences okay so so
I'm gonna stop there because I'm I'm uh
out of time almost uh let me just end by
noticing that a bunch of the people I've
talked to about today won the the vanman
theory prize and in in 2022 VJ want it
as well so there's a uh
you know a nice group of people who have
worked on matching who have won the
vorman prize it must be an important
area to work in thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you okay I take it that all the proofs
were
convincing